pois bem exatamente há três semanas
atrás
nós estávamos nos divertindo na represa
de avaré meu filho pedro minha nora bete
aliás a causadora desse vídeo e corre
quando cheguei é pulando pra leste
depois que a arm diz conseguir conseguir
a ré que conseguiu filmar
então você escuta é que ela já me
incomodei muito não só achei que não
devia ter esperado um pouco eu poder me
fazer nem sabia nem me dei conta que a
gente filmava a ser pra ver qual é a
nossa performance que todos nós gostamos
de cada vez melhorar um pouco os então
uns dias depois que eu soube que 10 mil
pessoas já tinham visto meu vídeo eu
fiquei pasma
pra mim é uma coisa assim simples e vir
não achava que era tanta coisa assim tão
maravilhosa mas é maravilhosa assim eu
adoro esquiar
adoro eu acho o máximo e me sinto
poderosa
me sinto livre me sinto sabe é ver
conquistando coisas
aquele medo que a gente sempre tem um
pouco quando vai fazer alguma coisa
assim diferente de levantar só que eu
vou levantar será que não vou
bom mas é uma maravilha mas sobretudo
uma grande gratidão a deus por tudo que
ele tem me usado
eu comecei esse que é mais tarde 17 anos
depois que eu já tive o décimo filho
e continua esquentando continua
esquerdos que até hoje e é uma coisa
muito importante para mim
mas você sabe é dizer que meus filhos
naturalmente que eles skill né eu
ensinei lógico os netos risquinho eu
ensinei os bisnetos já estão esquerda
também porque sabem que eu tenho 20
bisnetos
ah ah ah quem puxava sempre que era quem
pilotava sempre era meu marido marcelo e
ele até 90 anos era ele que me puxava
agora são os filhos e netos porque meu
marido já não está nesse mundo faz dois
meses mas ele está lá vendo e quando vou
esquiar eu lembro sempre foi meu bebê se
vai bem dessa vez é essa eu sei que é
depois de de velha como vocês estão
vendo né eu já vivia até arriscando um
pouco melhor né tantos anos atrás mas é
eu sei que isso tudo é muito bonito isso
que é muito bonito eu nadava também
todos os portes de água eu em sánchez
também fazia porque eu gosto muito de
água e se sabe porque eu acho que eu
tive esse prazer de água eu aprendi com
meu avô paterno eles se sabe que quando
era bem que querem lá na fazenda dele
ele me levava o globo
vi lado gelado nós vamos todos os dias
às sete da manhã descalços na enviada
para nadar e essa mania de água apesar
da geada apesar do frio apesar da hora e
acho que aqui ficou pra mim pra sempre
esse avô teve muita influência aliás o
avô e avó
os dois que tiveram influência na minha
vida e eles tinham uma família bastante
grande
bastante grande mesmo 14 filhos onze
mulheres e era muito divertido na casa
deles é sempre alegria que ela
linha daquela preparada pra cá foi um
palaque o palavra e sempre alegre sempre
divertido sempre brincalhões dramas
nunca nunca
eu sei que aquilo ficou na minha cabeça
eu cheguei aqui eu fui educada com muito
muito amor mas também com muito rigor
duas frases marcaram bastante na minha
vida que foi você que é dona da sua vida
e você é que vai ver como é que você
quer que ela seja ea outra que é a vida
não tem rascunho
eu sei que eu fui indo com isso eu fui
passando eu queria muito o casal
obviamente naquele tempo ninguém pensava
em fazer grandes carreiras e apesar de
ter sido formado em economia ninguém
pensava nem queria casar eu tinha 16
anos e meio eu conheci marcelo fiquei
muito impressionada com ele
cheguei em casa na primeira dica é
conhecido se escolhe hoje conheci o amor
com que eu voltasse à frente normalmente
você foi com seu namorado lá eu a mãe
ser o outro um ano e meio depois eu
estava casado havia e dessa história
casa meu tenho outra história engraçada
que marcelo não pediu pra casa ele ele
disse assim se quer casar comigo eu
declaro meu amorzinho
só que eu tenho uma tem uma exigência
muito grande ele falecesse fininho sabe
aí revirando o olho
a escola é meu bebê e eu quero ter dez
filhos e sabe que ele já aceitou na hora
e assim é e nós temos mesmo uma família
muito grande muito unidos e são muito
queridos e e eu só posso agradecer a
deus nem sabe por que eu vou contar um
pouco pra vocês que família grande e é
muito divertido viu se eu fosse contar
toda nem tem o mesmo palavra de falar
mas eu vou contar para vocês acontece de
tudo como por exemplo eu esquecer um
filho no lugar por exemplo tínhamos a
comida e punha todas as crianças dentro
de si nessa altura eu tinha eu tinha
oito filhos acho que nessa altura vamos
passear lá na ilha porchat voltávamos
para casa felizes quando eu vejo a dell
carlos thadeu carlos
o infeliz tinha quatro anos atrás
bom essa é uma por exemplo teve outra
que o mário é o número 6 é o marca
número 6
ele foi pegar uma coisa na janela porte
caiu do segundo andar quase morreu
depois teve aquela outra também por
exemplo que eu tinha preparado a casa
para o natal pintado blá blá blá
quando cheguei na copa vai verificar se
a corte em sabonete quando eu olho para
o céu para o céu quer dizer pra telhado
ali tudo cheio de umas bolinhas
esquisitas de bolinhas são essas doce de
leite em volta de uva eles tinham
contato pado todo o telhado rodou
telhador pode ser uma coisa dessas
bom não pode né não pode é depois de
casada ano passado um pouco aquele tempo
só róseo e sabe de que está se está a
felicidade
eu percebi percebia
acho que a gente vai ouvindo vai vendo
as coisas aqui eu não estava aqui só
para passear
então resolvi que nós devemos fazer
alguma coisa pelos outros e além da
minha família porque se há-de imaginar
que dá bastante trabalho né
a cimeira de um ou outro não sabe mas
até hoje quando eu fico consoles a sou
filho único
é mas então eu resolvi em primeira coisa
que nós fizemos fizemos com os amigos
nós eo chamou de até hoje entre a turma
do tricô
nós fazíamos enxoval para as crianças e
das mães solteiras e nós éramos 32 hoje
nós somos 12 mas até hoje olha faz 65
anos que nós temos esse grupo
depois disso eu acho que é sofrer usado
colégios onde estudei e elas me viu com
aquela ficharada de tudo então
resolveram me chamar pedal de namoro
orde namoro depois e é desses clubes
demais a trabalhar bastante tempo lá
depois não só eu fui trabalhar
aí teve uma virada na minha vida e eu
precisei a nossa vida eu precisei
trabalhar e eu fui trabalhar na tv
cultura onde não fiquei quase 20 anos
naturalmente quando cheguei teve o que
chama de hoje bullying é que faça uma
garoa fina aqui que vai fazer uma grande
fila aqui bom eu sei que eu ganhei o
prêmio da paz ea viu isso eu ganhei mas
é fazer a programas de tudo sabe sobre
viagem sobre é esporte sobre educação
enfim de tudo que se possa imaginar
fazer o programa teve uma vez a ter um
tempo até que eu tinha três problemas
por semana de meia hora
é uma loucura pra fazer quem estás
televisão sabe disso que eu não produzir
e apresentava e também fazia depois da
revisão toda depois da televisão eu fui
pra eu fui pra liga das senhoras
católicas que a uma instituição que já
está com quase 100 anos e que é cuidar
de mais de 10 mil crianças jovens idosos
e famílias
foi um trabalho bonito fiquei lá até
acabar numa meus mandatos de presidente
foram 13 anos lá
depois disso eu sei que lá na na liga
tem boas boas recordações porque a gente
vê aquele mundo de gente que a gente
pode ajudar e depois dá lhe é dada
quando acabou meu tempo
eu estava lá a fita na minha vida na
minha escrivaninha lá o que eu vou fazer
agora que eu vou fazer agora fui chamada
pra ir pra c d e lá na cdl estou eu
estou eu trabalho lá com as mães das
crianças deficientes e e eu trabalho bem
bonito é um projeto borboleta e nesse
projeto borboleta viu que o que eu
imaginei era assim é que elas vissem
outras possibilidades das vidas delas do
que ser apenas uma destas crianças
deficientes é assim sair do casulo para
serem borboletas alegres e coloridas e
elas têm psicólogos toda semana ainda
agora nós mandávamos elas passear num
hotel fazenda os filhos é elas têm
naturalmente que tem essa parte de
aprender costura artesanato e vendem
esses artesanato que são muito bonitos
isso é uma propaganda e é com isso elas
também faz um dinheirinho e tudo mas
agora então voltamos para aquilo que eu
estava querendo dizer pelo esqui
o que tem que ver o esqui com isso tudo
você sabe o que é é o esqui ou qualquer
outro esporte pra mim eu esquiar natação
candado também quase todo dia é uma
coisa assim o tempo mil
eu acho que nesse tempo que nós estamos
vivendo em que tudo correndo tudo
estresse tudo é uma correria danada você
não pode fazer nada é um tempo meu o
tempo esse meu tempo de esporte é um
tempo meu que eu tenho pra mim que eu
posso pensar que eu posso
devagar que eu posso enfim ser vou ser
eu mesmo e envia um pouco as coisas como
são
o tempo que eu possa meditar é o tempo
que esporte por si só é um desafio você
tem que ter força de vontade
você tem que fazer um pequeno sacrifício
depois gozar da da história por exemplo
pode estar muito frio eu vou pra água
gelada
não tô com vontade de entrar nas ruas
que eu adoro mas você tem que ter uma
certa
terminação sport sabe que dar todas a
essa competição tudo isso e isso tudo
ajuda na vida ajuda na vida eu acho que
é é uma coisa que é importante é por
isso que estou falando do esqui mais
perto qualquer um que faça qualquer
esporte é a mesma coisa então eu acho
que todo mundo poderia fazer isso pra
vocês verem como agente renasce isso nós
todos temos que ter e eu graças a deus
tive todos os dias um tempo para
agradecer a deus pai todo poderoso que
nos ama tanto que nos quer também quer
nos acompanhar e quero facilitar a vida
e nos quer feliz
esse é o milagre da minha vida humana